hey guys how's it going it's Justine
today I'm tasting candy and it's not a
lot of candy
these are sugarfina nintendo themed two
candies and I got them on Bloomingdale's
website I don't even know if you guys
know this or not the Bloomingdale's has
been doing this little partnership with
a Nintendo they have really cool
displays in their stores I was freaking
out when I saw that this was a thing
because obviously I love Nintendo I know
I don't really talk about it much but I
shop at Bloomingdale's way too much so
it's like the combination of two of my
favorite things yeah you better believe
I was excited and then I went on the
website and I was like what it's
probably like midnight when I first saw
that they started releasing this stuff
and I was getting super super excited
but the thing is all of the women's
stuff was just slightly inspired by
Nintendo they had like a Marc Jacobs
green and red purse for Mario and Luigi
they had some rainbow sweaters and they
had some weird little graphic tees or
sweaters that say like game on or game
over play on I'm not really sure they
did have a few little accessories like a
purse with peach on it I think they had
some iPhone cases but they were not for
the iPhone 10 so a lot of things took my
excitement level and just knocked it
down a little bit and then I was even
more upset because when I went and
looked at the men's clothes they had
super cute little character t-shirts so
they basically had everything that I
wanted but it was all for the guys which
is fine I could have just bought the
guy's clothes but then it's gonna fit
like a guy a shirt on my knot guy body
he's so upset but then I saw this
these are sugarfina candies they have
Super Mario clouds Yoshi eggs and
strawberry mushrooms so they redeem
themselves but still I'm a little upset
about it although I did buy the camo
fanny pack and the camo book bags so at
least those things are coming but I said
like the ship time was like 40 days or
something silly but whatever I'm still
excited about it
let's do a little taste test of these
candies I also bought these four row
because sugarfina is one of her favorite
candies and obviously it's nintendo
themed so I think she's gonna be into it
first up let's try the Super Mario
clouds
I don't want to ruin their beautiful
packaging so I'm just gonna kind of give
it a slice just like that mmm
this is a nice taste I can't even figure
out what it is
hmm it's some type of fruit it's kind of
like a crunchy maybe an apricot maybe
coconut could be coconut I'm not sure
like I can't really tell it was kind of
crunchy potentially an apricot maybe
coconut I don't know I'm not a very good
taste tester this taste test is a taste
test fail even though I don't know what
the taste was it tastes it good so
that's a plus let's try one of the Yoshi
eggs next oh these are massive look at
this let's try this big pink one oh
whatever it's like some sort of lookup
chocolaty molten ball oh yeah it is a
real crunchy little delight mmm so far I
think that the yoshi eggs are my
favorite out of the two that i've tried
so far i love chocolate so anything
chocolate is a win in my book this is
interesting because all these other ones
they made in the USA but the strawberry
mushrooms say that they're made in
Sweden let's taste it up the design on
these stickers and packaging is spot-on
it's really beautiful density done so
here's the gummy
it has a red little top just like toad
and a white little squishy bottom so
this just looks like a little strawberry
gummy doesn't exactly look like toad I
don't know it kind of looks like a
turtle shell if you ask me let's taste
it mmm
very very chewy I also think I might
have a cavity because this is a little
bit painful this tastes really really
good I think because it has that little
bottom white part they kind of had it
more of a like milky kind of flavor to
it or like a texture so it sort of
tasted like a strawberry milkshake okay
so now I think the strawberry one is my
favorite so it's gonna go toad - Yoshi -
of the clouds these are so cute I don't
want to eat any more of them because
they I feel like they're collectors
items and I want to save that
I know this is kind of a short little
video but I was so excited about these
that I wanted to share it with you guys
before they run out this is not
sponsored in any way I bought these no
hashtag ad I just thought they're really
awesome and I did want you guys to miss
out especially because I know a lot of
you guys are huge didn't endow fans and
I didn't even know this thing existed
especially if you don't shop at
Bloomingdale's very often it's something
that could be easily missed by a lot of
intento fans so feel free to check it
out let me know what you think and
ladies or are you just as upset as I am
about their Nintendo inspired collection
I get it it's inspired by Nintendo let's
be real I want the shirts that you have
for the guys for us equal opportunity
here and you missed 50% of it I'll see
you guys in my next video that's it I'm
gonna go probably eat the rest of these
now see you later
before I go did anybody else use the
Mario and Google Maps for Mario day it
was the best thing ever
it still is working right now so I've
still been using it for the past couple
of days I love it
[Music]